waste in restaurants is exorbitant if  you saw how much waste is in a  restaurant it's sickening in fine dining  you want everything to be perfect  vegetables don't come perfectly shaped  you need to cut them to be perfectly  shaped which means what happens to all  the trim when you're trimming it down to  get a perfect little square on a piece  of meat what happens to all the little  strips of meat you just cut off the big  restaurant trash cans you know which one  I'm talking about the ones that are  [ __ ] horrible to fill with the bag  let's say six of those get rotated maybe  three to four times a night 350 days out  of the year for one restaurant